[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRAJAKTA JOSHI:
Welcome to our session.
I'm Prajakta.
I'm a product manager
in Cloud networking.
So I'm sure some of
you are Cloud natives.
Some of you are
Enterprise customers.
And one of the interesting
things is when we talk
to our Enterprise customers,
they say we want to deliver
smart, secure, modern
services, but we cannot.
They think because they
have deployments on-prem,
or because they think
it's difficult to deliver
global services at scale with
five nines of availability,
or they think that
micro services
are cool but not for them.
Whether you are an
Enterprise or a Cloud native,
our goal today is
to show you how
you can deliver smart, secure,
modern services on Google Cloud
Platform.
So lets get started.
Let's start with smart
application delivery.
What smart smarts do our
customers ask us for?
They say, deliver
our services close
to our users across the globe.
They say, help us deliver
reliable services with five
nines of availability.
Scale our services up or down
in line with our traffic.
Optimize our services
for latency and cost.
And enable us to deliver
and move our services
across GCP on-prem and clouds.
That is what smart application
delivery is about--
global, reliable, autoscaled,
optimized, and portable.
There are five key
building blocks
that enable smart
application delivery--
Cloud load balancing, Cloud CDN,
Cloud interconnect, Kubernetes,
and the Container Engine.
Now, before we start talking
about global load balancing,
first let's talk about
Google Cloud load balancing.
I'm going to ask you one thing.
Forget everything you
know about load balances.
Let's start fresh.
So we have five types of
load balancing solutions,
and we are going to focus
on global load balancing.
So essentially,
HTTP load balancing
for HTTP traffic and your
HTTP/2 traffic as well.
HTTP is load balancing
for HTTPS traffic.
For your non-HTTP traffic, we
have SSL proxy for your TLS
traffic, and then TCP proxy
for your unencrypted traffic.
Let's start with global
application delivery.
There are numerous
reasons why you
might want to deliver your
workloads or your services
globally.
Maybe you want to deliver your
services around the globe.
Maybe you need the highest
levels of availability,
so you want to replicate
your services in all regions
around the world.
Or maybe you want to deliver
your services with low latency
by being close to your users.
This is what Google global load
balancing enables you to do.
Instantiate your resources
across the globe,
frontend these with a
single, frontend VIP,
and deliver low
latency, high bandwidth
connectivity to your users.
And with all of this, think of
the Google global load balancer
as having infinite capacity, so
it'll never be a choke point.
Like I said before,
forget everything
you know about load balancers.
Let's look at this.
The load balancer to your left
is a traditional load balancer.
On the right is the Google
global load balancing.
You might ask, where
is the load balancer?
There is really no
load balancer there.
That's exactly the point.
The load balancing is all
software and is done by GFEs,
the Google frontends.
The GFEs themselves
are distributed
around the globe
in Google's POPs
and the load balance in sync
with each other by working
with other software defined
systems and the global control
plane.
Now, these GFEs
terminate your traffic
closest to your user and load
balance the user requests
to the closest healthy backend
with available capacity.
So for a minute, just
focus on the gray dots
that you see on this map.
These are Google's POPs, and
they host the Google frontends.
This is where your Google
global load balancing
happens, close to your users.
And then the traffic
gets sent to an instance
in the closest data center
over Google's high quality,
high performance global network.
Let's look at this technology
through an example.
A key technology that is used
in Google global load balancing
is intelligent anycast.
Basically, as shown
in the example,
you can deploy your service
backends wherever you want, so
in any of the regions.
In this example, you have
them in US west, in Europe,
and in Asia.
But now is the interesting bit--
what you will notice is
you frontended all of them
with a single VIP.
In another cloud provider,
you would have required
three VIPs, one per region.
And I want to make an
interesting announcement.
So we have supported global
load balancing for IPv4 clients
for now close to two years.
And today, we're excited to
introduce Google global load
balancing for IPv6
clients as well.
So shown in this example, your
service myapp.com has a single
v6 VIP, 2001:db8::10.
And so Maya in
California, Bob in London,
and Shen in Singapore, they
all can connect to your service
using a single, anycast
VIP, 2001:db8::10.
The request is
automatically load
balanced to the
instance closest to them
with available capacity.
So this is a unique
differentiation
for Google's global
load balancing.
You will not get this in
any other cloud provider.
So now that we talked about
Google global load balancing,
one of the key considerations
for any solution
is performance.
And so when we launched the
Google global load balancer,
I think about two years back, we
wanted to see how it performs,
and we threw a lot
of traffic at it.
We stopped at 1 million
requests per second
because it just went
on and on and on,
handling the
requests seamlessly.
Another great example,
so how many of you
are familiar with Pokemon Go?
How many of you are not
familiar with Pokemon Go?
So Pokemon Go is a great example
of the scale and performance
Google global load
balancing can deliver.
So when the game was
first introduced,
within 15 minutes of
launching this game,
the player traffic
really surged.
In fact, the traffic was 50x of
the initial target and 10 times
the worst case estimate.
We obviously needed
to do something
to handle this traffic,
so Pokemon applications
were moved to containers.
They were orchestrated
at this massive scale
using Google Container Engine.
And these container backends
were frontended by the HTTPS
load balancing to handle
the massive traffic
that Pokemon Go was seeing.
So all your traffic was actually
being handled by the Google
global load balancer.
So now we talked about
delivering your services
globally.
What next?
The next thing you want to do
is to optimize your services
for latency and cost.
And a really great tool
to use for this purpose
is content delivery networks.
Now, what a CDN does is it
caches your site's content
all around the world, speeding
delivery to your users,
while also offloading
your origins.
And so Google Cloud platform
has its own native solution
called Cloud CDN.
And we also have seven
interconnect partners.
So essentially what
you have is choice.
Just like cloud load
balancing, Cloud CDN
is also delivered using Google's
high performance global network
and the Edge
infrastructure, of course.
It uses Google's 80-plus
points of presence
to accelerate content
delivery for your websites
and for your
applications, and these
could be served out of Compute
Engine or out of storage
as well.
So two interesting
things I wanted
to point out about Cloud CDN.
One, that it is very tightly
integrated with the Google
Cloud platform.
So if you've set up HTTP
or HTTPS load balancing,
you can just enable it
with a single checkbox.
The other thing I wanted to
point out, I think most of you
know that Google believes
in TLS everywhere.
So we do not charge extra for
TLS traffic, so for HTTPS.
And so we recommend that
as a default configuration.
You will not be paying anything
extra for CDN for using TLS.
So we talked earlier about
this tight integration,
and we said you
could enable Cloud
CDN with a single checkbox.
I also wanted to discuss a new
feature that we're introducing.
Now, Cloud CDN also
gets its own UI.
You can see on the screen
there is a left navigation
bar that has Cloud CDN.
So now you can go here,
as well, and configure
all of the advanced
configurations
and special knobs that
you need for your CDN.
You're the first
people actually looking
at this snapshot of the screen,
but it just rolled out today.
So please try it out.
Just like cloud load
balancing, performance
is, again, a very key
consideration for Cloud CDNs.
How many of you have
heard of Cedexis?
Great.
So Cedexis is essentially
a web traffic optimization
and analytics company, and
they recently published data
on the Cloud CDN performance.
So I've included the
link on the slide.
I'm just going to walk you
through some of the highlights.
As you can see here,
Google Cloud CDN
has much lower latency than
our public cloud competitors.
So we have our
competitor and ours.
Ours is the line in green.
So lower the latency better.
It has much higher
availability as well.
So again, you can see the
green line is on the top.
And it definitely has much
higher throughput as well.
So I purposely added
the link to the report
so you can view it offline.
So we talked about
global load balancing,
and we talked about
optimizing your workloads.
But one of the things that
most of you bring to us is--
we have a deployment on-prem,
or we are in two clouds,
and Google is an open cloud.
So the interesting thing about
either migrating or managing
across clouds is that you
require the right set of tools.
We don't have enough time
to go into all of the tools,
but I did want to talk about
two tools that our customers use
frequently.
One such tool for
multi-cloud automation
that several of our GCP
customers use is Terraform.
It's a tool by HashiCorp.
Now, Terraform has a
declarative config,
and so operators can very
predictably and safely
create, modify, and destroy
production infrastructure
across multiple clouds.
So it's infrastructure
as code, basically.
Another popular tool that we see
a lot of enterprises and cloud
natives use is Spinnaker.
And so if you look at
the sample dashboard,
this is a snippet of a
live dashboard from Waze.
And as you can see
on the dashboard,
Waze is able to manage both
GCP and AWS using Spinnaker
in a single pane of glass.
And there are many such
tools, so I think just
finding the right set of
tools to manage your migration
and deployment also makes
it much, much easier.
But the best
portability actually
comes from making your
workloads portable,
and you can do this
with containers.
We have excellent
sessions on containers
throughout this conference.
Once you have your workloads
that are containerized,
you can orchestrate
them with Kubernetes,
which is our open source
container orchestration tool.
Or you can use Google
Container Engine.
It's essentially our managed
version of Kubernetes
on Google Cloud.
And there's a reason
I put this slide here.
If you will notice, there is
a bunch of enterprises in here
and cloud natives as well.
And so you can see
that both of them
use Google Container Engine
and Kubernetes for workload
portability.
I highly recommend that you look
at these two services as well.
So we talked about modern,
and we delivered our workloads
across the globe, and
then we optimized them,
and then we took care of
hybrid cloud and multi-cloud.
The next thing is, think of
any of the Google services
that you use.
Let's say Surge
or Gmail or Drive,
and you automatically
have a secure connection,
or TLS connection, to Google.
So just like that
you have a variety
of tools to actually secure your
services in the Google Cloud.
I'm going to focus on four
aspects of secure application
delivery.
One, controlled access to
your application instances,
delivering private services,
TLS everywhere, and something
that's on the top of
your mind, DDoS defense.
You have four building
blocks in here,
so let's walk through them.
The first one is essentially
controlling access
to your instances.
This is basically
determining who gets access
to your instance and who is
denied access to your instance.
A key tool that
you can use here is
the GCP distributed firewall.
So often people ask us,
like, what is distributed?
Or what does it mean
in this context?
Unlike traditional
firewalls, where
you have to actually
take the traffic
and steer it to a metal
box, which often itself
becomes a choke
point, GCP enforces
the firewall rules on the
application instance itself,
and hence the term distributed.
The second one is just like
we talked about global load
balancing.
A lot of you run micro
services, or services
that you want to
keep private and not
exposed to the internet.
So we recently introduced
internal load balancing,
which allows you to run
and scale your services,
or your micro
services, privately.
And the load
balancing IP address
is again, RFC 1918
private address.
So you can see an
example on the screen
where you have instances running
in subnet two and subnet three,
and an internal
client from subnet one
is able to access
the service privately
without going to the internet.
One interesting thing I want to
point out-- so people tell us,
like, you have all of these
tricks under the hood,
and that is true even for
internal load balancing.
Just like other Google global
load balancing flavors,
the internal load balancing
is not a managed instance
or appliance-based solution.
It is architected
using Andromeda,
so that is our software-defined
network virtualization stack.
And so basically there is
really no internal load balancer
in the path, which is what
you see on the screen.
It can scale as
much as is needed
to handle your workloads,
so there is, again,
no choke point in your network.
The third thing
is TLS everywhere.
So if your traffic is HTTPS, you
can use HTTPS load balancing.
And for all of your non-HTTPS
traffic which is encrypted,
you can use SSL proxy.
This is, again, a new flavor we
introduced a few months back.
It went GA a few months back.
And both HTTPS load
balancing and SSL proxy
are global load
balancing flavors,
which means you can offload your
TLS traffic for your instances
no matter where they are.
Whichever region they are,
with a single anycast VIP,
just like we talked
about before.
As I mentioned before,
both cloud load balancing
and Cloud CDN do not charge
extra for TLS traffic.
So there no reason you should
not be using TLS traffic.
And then DDoS defense--
so we haven't talked
about it before,
but I don't know
how many of you know
that when you deploy Google
Cloud load balancing or Cloud
CDN, you actually get implicit
layer three and layer four DDoS
protection.
So things such as against TCP
SYN floods, or IP fragmentation
attacks, and so on.
You can complement this
further with protection
from our third party
DDoS providers.
So you see a few of
them on the screen,
like Cloudflare, Fastly,
Akamai, and several others.
And so I wanted to end
the secure part of it
with this blueprint.
I'm not going to go
into a lot of details,
but think of it as protecting
layer with another layer.
So you have your secure VPC.
You have your secure
hybrid connectivity.
You complement that with third
party virtual appliances.
Then you deploy the Google
global load balancer
to get the DDoS defense.
And then you finally have
Google's high capacity,
high performance,
global network.
And you get protection even
against UDP-based attacks.
And then all of
this you complement
using the DDoS Defense
from third party providers.
It's just a layered
approach to security
that will keep your
services secure.
So we talked about smart,
and we talked about security.
Now I'd like to invite my
colleague, Anna, to come
and talk about modern services.
Anna, please come up.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNA BERENBERG:
Thank you, Prajakta.
My name is Anna
Berenberg, and I'm
a TL of load
balancing in Google.
And today we're
going to be talking
about modern application
delivery on GCP.
And what does modern mean?
It's modular, optimized,
composable, and open.
And it's all achievable with
the help of this Google Cloud
and open source solutions.
Let's look at the evolution
of services to microservices.
We can start with the
ancient age of 15,
20 years ago, when we had
a monolithic application
and all the functionality
was built into it.
And as our users started to
demand a lot of functionality,
we naturally split
up location services.
Once we knew how to split,
we split and split more,
until we split
into microservices.
And here we are
today at the stage
of modern
microservices, where we
are saying that the
future of microservices
is containers, serverless,
gRPC for transport layer
to microservices, load balancing
to bind all the microservices
together to a service.
Google itself spent 15
years running microservices.
There are three basic
building blocks.
There is a Borg, which
is container management
system at Google, which we
open sourced as Kubernetes
and brought it back
to the Cloud as GKE.
There is a Stubby, which
is internal transport
layer between open
source as gRPC
and now is available
in the Cloud.
And there is a GSLB/GFE, which
are our global load balancing
solution that powers up cloud
load balancing that Prajakta
was talking about.
As you can see,
microservices can
be spread across multiple
environments on Google Cloud.
But if you look
underneath, they're
all powered by a single Google
load balancing infrastructure.
And for some environments,
some environments
use the explicit products,
like cloud load balancing,
and some manage environment,
like App Engine or Cloud
Functions, are using
Google load balancing
infrastructure internally.
There are four basic
load balancing products,
and they're going into
different dimensions.
You can slice them, whether
they're global or regional,
whether they serve external
or internal traffic,
and different protocols.
More flavors are coming.
And if you can look here
at backend service API,
this is the API
that actually allows
us to configure microservice.
Let's look at the microservice
deployment in Google Cloud.
Aside from managed deployments
like App Engine and Google
Functions, we can load at the
Container Engine and Compute
Engine.
And you can see
that on an instance
you can have two
applications, each
with one board and
applications, or the instance
with one application
and multiple boards,
or have GKE pods with
one or many boards.
And we can load balance
to microservice endpoints.
We'll be taking example today of
delivering traffic microservice
to the images and
videos of cats and dog.
How many of you
watch videos of cats?
Yay.
According to
tubularinsights.com,
there were 25 billion
videos watched on YouTube,
and dogs don't even
come anywhere close.
So with such, we're going
to split the service
into two microservices, right?
One for dogs, one for cats.
And in front of
each microservice,
we'll put a load
balancer, so we can
obstruct the set of
servers that change
their geolocation, their health,
their number of services,
with just a single
load balanced IP port.
We call it VIP.
Even though
microservices are small,
their needs are very large.
But today, due to
time limit, we are
going to be talking only
about load balancing, auto
scaling, health checking,
and high availability.
Let's talk about modular part
of modern application delivery.
Besides optimizing
for modularity,
for event driven interfaces,
and improved velocity,
we also want to optimize for
resource utilization, user
and service perceived latency,
and the custom behavior
each microservice can exhibit.
We already talked before how
to split cats and dogs based
on amount of QPS,
but here you can also
say that if I have a different
set of URLs or names,
I can actually have a
microservice for each endpoint
that can be named.
Or you can split the
microservices by a bottleneck.
Let's say images are
CPU bound, while videos
are connection bound.
As you can see, not everybody
likes cats and dogs equally.
So what do we do?
When we try to place
our microservices,
we need to look how to
place microservices as
close to the user as possible.
That's one.
And the second thing,
we can actually
optimize by placing services
only where they need it.
For example, there is no need
to place a lot of cats in Asia
because dogs enjoy a
2.5 to 1 advantage.
So talking more
about optimization,
we can optimize
delivery of traffic
based on the behavior
of different bottleneck
of the services.
For example, for
the images, we can
configure load balancing
be arrayed-based,
and the capacity, let's
say, of 1,000 RPS.
While for videos,
they're connection-based,
and so we will provision,
let's say, 500 connection.
And let's say we have
a set of instances
that share these microservices
on each instance.
What's going to happen
that we will load
balance traffic independently.
So as soon as the
first, let's say,
the images will reach 1,000
RPS within a single zone,
the traffic would be
moved away without regards
to how many connections
the videos are receiving
on the same instances.
So each microservice load
balanced independently.
Or let's say we have a set of
microservices that share a CPU.
So we want to optimize
CPU resource utilization,
but we also don't want to
overwhelm CPU with one of the,
let's say, we have
a jumping cat video,
which is going to
probably use more
CPU than the serving images.
And so in this case, we
notify Cloud auto scaler
how to sum up CPU utilization
of all the microservices
that run on the same instance.
And then auto scaler
will increase or decrease
number of instances based
on common utilization.
Let's say auto scaling
is not enabled.
Let's say you're application
cannot use auto scaler.
Then the load
balancer itself knows
what are the microservices
that share these instances.
And it will consider
traffic as a sum of traffic
across all the microservices
within this instance
and move the traffic away
as soon as it reaches
configured target utilization.
So to provide minimal
interruption to a service,
to traffic, when the instance
is removed or terminated,
we provide connection draining.
So only new connections
are being delivered
to non-drained instances.
The drained instances continue
to serve existing connection
until configured
timeout expires.
So if we look here
at the example,
let's say there
are two instances--
A and B. And let's
say it's evening,
and the traffic goes down.
So instance A is sufficient to
serve traffic for both images
and videos, and
Cloud auto scaler
wants to bring down instance
B. Then in this case,
it will wait until both
connections are being drained,
and you would imagine that for
videos the connection timeout
will be much longer
than for the images.
And so it will wait until
both of them drain out,
and only then it will
take down the instance.
We provide health checking
for microservices.
So it's, again, not per
instances, not per GKE board,
but actually per microservice
for each IP board
that is available.
Different protocols,
content-based health check,
and per microservice
configuration,
where you can configure
different probes,
different number until
healthy, unhealthy, et cetera.
Let's look at the example
of composable application
delivery.
So we talked about--
first, we split, then we
talked about optimization,
and now we are talking how
to take the microservices
and actually make a
service out of it.
And here is an example of
typical three tier application
that is spread across different
Google cloud environments,
and are using also our
Cloud managed services
that are high availability
and where high availability is
actually achieved through
load balanced failover,
like Cloud Scale.
And that's another example
of a non-tiered architecture.
I can go a little bit
deeper in this example,
because let's say somebody
uploads the image of the dog,
and it goes to image services.
Image services will call up
Cloud Functions with a Pub/Sub
to get some special effects.
And then it sends it to machine
learning for breed tagging,
and then for geotagging
to get to know
where the dog is most popular.
And then it gets saved,
let's say, in the GCS.
And once it hits GCS,
it triggers GCS event
in a Cloud Function.
And then this Cloud function
produces no less than rotating
puppy.
And rotating puppy with
breed tagging and geotagging
gets saved back into the GCS.
And so when some user
asks for a puppy,
it gets a GIF of
rotating puppy, known
as a bulldog, which
is also known to be
very popular in New York City.
Let's talk about open part of
modern application delivery.
We use gRPCs open
source transport layer.
And there are a
lot of advantages
of using this because it's
based on protocol buffers.
It allows for
backward compatibility
and language operability.
And because it has
layered extensions,
it allows for two layer
authentication, load balancing,
and logging.
And because it allows to send
the service configuration
to client, it
allows service owner
to control the client settings.
Typically when we talk about
microservice load balancing,
we talk about load balancing
type of proxies, right?
But there are a lot of different
ways of load balanced traffic.
You can have a
proxy in the middle.
You can have side car.
Or you can have what's called
one arm load balancing.
One arm load balancing
is interesting
because it's actually
not on data path.
And so it doesn't
introduce extra latency,
and it doesn't become a
choke point like Prajakta
was alluding before.
So you don't have to
over provision it.
And so in this situation,
your initial connection
goes to load balancer.
And then subsequently,
load balance
streams on the background
backend to the client,
so the clients can talk
to servers directly.
And the reason I'm
talking about it
is because at Google that's what
we are using for internal load
balancing.
We're using one
arm load balancer,
and we're hoping to
bring it soon to Cloud.
And so to recap
and to summarize,
modern microservices
on Google Cloud
benefit for
fine-grained scalability
through load balancing
and auto scaling.
It also allows you
to mix and match
your services and our
managed cloud services.
And the future of Compute is
a Container Engine and Cloud
Function.
Thank you.
I would like to introduce
Ravi Yedulla, Senior
Director of the Home Depot.
[APPLAUSE]
RAVI YEDDULA: Thank you, Anna.
My name is Ravi Yeddula.
I'm a senior director
on the homedepot.com
team responsible for Cloud
platform architecture
and the migration of
homedepot.com to Google Cloud.
I've been with Home Depot
for the last six years.
And for the last
15 to 18 months,
I've gotten to know
Google really well.
I'm really excited to be here
and share our story with you
guys today.
So my talk is going
to be broken down
into three different parts.
First, I'm going to talk
about why cloud native
and why public cloud.
And then I'm going to talk
about basically a hybrid cloud
architecture and cloud
native architecture.
And then I'm going to close out
with the key lessons learned
as part of this journey.
Before we begin the talk,
just a raise of hands.
How many of you recognize
Home Depot here today?
How many of you don't?
Great.
So Home Depot is one of the most
recognized and iconic brands
in the US.
It's the world's largest
home improvement retailer
with well over 2,000 stores
in the US, Canada, and Mexico,
and generated over $94
billion in revenue last year.
Many of you might know the
large physical footprint
of Home Depot, but
we are actually
a really big e-commerce shop.
We are, in fact, a top
10 e-commerce website
and generated over $5
billion in revenue last year.
From an industry
recognition perspective,
in 2016, Fast Company
recognized Home Depot as one
of the top 50 most innovative
companies in the US.
And in fact, we are the
only retailer in that group,
among the likes of
Apple and Google.
In 2015, we were also recognized
as the internet retailer
of the year for our pioneer
and interconnected retail
against the competition
of Amazon and Wal-Mart.
And last but not the least,
we are absolutely hiring--
hiring cloud software engineers,
cloud product engineers.
And if you're interested in
helping us sell more nails
and hammers, please hit
me up after the talk.
Great.
So our journey to the cloud.
So why cloud native?
Many might actually
look at cloud native
as a technology decision.
For us, it was actually
a business decision.
It was to help us unlock real
business value and agility
and deliver more features
and benefits to our ever
increasing expectations of
the e-commerce customers.
In fact, when I joined Home
Depot in 2010, all we could do
was basically add an item to the
cart and ship it to your house.
Today, you can ship the
products to the house,
you can pick up in the store,
you can ship to the store.
You can actually deliver
the product to the store.
You can specify a two hour
time slot to say, hey, deliver
my product from 10:00
AM to 12:00 PM--
between 10:00 AM and 12:00 PM.
And all that requires a really
solid technical architecture
foundation and the
capability to introduce
features really at a rapid pace.
For as many of you
are experiencing
[INAUDIBLE], like many
enterprises, pre-2012,
we were a large legacy
monolithic platform.
It was a big platform just
to serve one large team,
and we were all trying
to make changes.
And it was difficult
to make the changes,
because we had to regression
test the entire site.
As you can see,
the release cycles
were three months long,
multiple months long,
based on the complexity
of the release cycle.
And that's where we wanted
to do something about,
hey, how do we increase
the feature velocity
so that we can actually deliver
features at a much faster pace?
2012 to 2016, we actually broke
down our monolithic application
into what I call,
mini monoliths.
So we broke down our one large
application to between 15
to 20 different
small applications.
We realized benefits
pretty soon thereafter.
Some teams were able to
increase their feature velocity
from three months to a month.
There are partially
independent teams,
not all teams
became independent.
Some teams like Surge are
still locator, still finder,
because they were not part of
the core e-commerce bypath.
They were able to push out
features at a faster pace.
And as you can see,
some teams actually
were releasing between
two weeks to one month.
But it was not good enough.
If you wanted to
roll out something
like pick up in store,
you have to go all the way
from your product page
to search results,
search results to PLP to
product page and the cart.
How do you actually
decompose all those team
so that they can deliver
at a much faster pace?
So in late 2015, we decided
to go completely cloud native,
and that's where you
can see our site is now
broken up into about 80
microservices and growing.
We expect to top around
120 microservices
when it is completely done.
And now teams are able to
actually release between a day
to a week, depending on
their velocity and pace.
They're also mostly independent
teams, and that's the key.
Going to a microservice
architecture
is not about actually
decomposing the application.
It's actually enabling
the application teams
to be completely independent.
If your teams are
not independent,
it's actually worse off.
All you have created is
actually a distributed monolith.
You made your
architecture more complex,
but you created many
more communication paths
and dependencies across teams.
So make sure as part of your
journey, if you're doing it,
pass your test.
Are your teams really
independent or not?
So when we started
the cloud journey,
we wanted to make
sure that we have
core principles defined as part
of our moving to public cloud.
And as you can imagine, as
being a Fortune 25 company,
dealing with customer
data and PCI security
is at the forefront
and the first thing
that we want to make sure
that we get it right.
So we want to make sure
that we have the right tools
and processes in place to
protect our customer data.
Legacy homedepot.com actually
ran out of single data center.
If the data center
had any issues,
you would have site downtime,
and customers would not
be able to buy products or
actually research products
to buy in the store.
So one of the biggest
things that we set out to do
was we have to have multi
data center or multi region
high availability.
And then the third thing
that we wanted to do
was immutable infrastructure.
The legacy
homedepot.com platform,
we have some automation built
in, but most of the automation
was around starting and
stopping the servers,
taking servers offline.
But any configuration
changes were made directly
on the physical host.
So we didn't treat our
infrastructure as code.
And so if you had to
recreate an environment,
it took us weeks and
maybe up to a month
to replicate the
environments cleanly.
The repeatability was lost.
So we wanted to make
sure that we have
repeatability from the get go.
And that ties well
into the next one--
to achieve repeatability
you need automation.
With automation, you would
treat infrastructure as code.
And that way any time you want
to spin up a new environment,
you just execute your
automation scripts.
You want to make any changes,
you spin up new environment.
Don't make changes to the
existing infrastructure
that you just provisioned.
And last but not least, as
part of the microservice
architecture, or
when you're going
from one big monolithic
database to maybe 10
different databases, from
10 servers or 20 servers
to hundreds of small
servers, if you
don't have the right monitoring
and reliability engineering
principles, it becomes chaotic.
Because you don't
know what went wrong.
You'll just spin your wheels
trying to troubleshoot.
So you want to
make sure that you
have the right team and the
right policies in place that
enable the right monitoring
and reliability engineering
principles for us to
be successful as part
of this journey.
So I want to just jump
into the architecture
that we have in the cloud today.
As you can imagine,
homedepot.com
has a large
technology footprint.
We have 2,000 stores.
We have a lot of master data
that resides inside Home Depot.
We can't move all
of it to the cloud,
so we'll always be
in hybrid cloud mode.
I highly doubt we'll ever be
completely all into the cloud.
So we need to find ways
to move the master data--
whether it is product
catalog, images, metadata--
securely to the cloud.
And we closely partnered
with Google Cloud engineers,
used the Google Cloud
Interconnect product
and VPN to move the data
securely to the cloud.
And as you can see on
the right hand side,
we use all these
security features,
whether it is security
tags, firewall rules,
the right IM
policies to make sure
that the data lands
securely in the cloud.
The path between the Home Depot
data centers and Google Cloud
is multi geo-redundant.
We actually go over
three different paths.
One would be our east coast,
one would be our Midwest,
and one our West Coast.
So if any time any
path is unavailable,
we have a path back
into Google Cloud.
And the next one is
basically, as you can see,
the migration of homedepot.com
into Google Cloud
is not a big bang approach.
We migrated parts of it
over long periods of time.
And for that you might
have a shopping cart
running inside the
legacy shopping cart,
running in Home
Depot data centers,
and trying to talk
to a promotion
API in Google Cloud
and vice versa.
You have shopping cart in Google
Cloud, talking to an inventory
API inside the Home
Depot, because inventory
is global between
stores and online.
And to enable secure
communication between the two,
we worked closely
with Google engineers,
used the API
gateway on our side,
going through the
same interconnect path
to make sure that the data
is securely transferred
between the two locations.
Multi-region high availability--
as I said, from the
get go we wanted to
make sure that we
run across multiple regions.
So this was not--
homedepot.com didn't start
out just running in one region
and then added another
reason as built on.
We started out with US east
and US central from the get go.
Here I just show two
zones in each region.
We actually run out of
three zones in each.
The two zones here are
just for clarity purposes.
So we have three zones in US
central and three zones in US
east.
All the databases are
actually replicated
across all six zones.
So we have three copies in US
central, three copies in US
east, and we also make a
backup every day back into GCS.
This is actually one of
the strongest features
for choosing Google Cloud.
In Google Cloud,
VPC, our project,
all regions are
globally visible.
Basically the VMs are globally
visible across US east and US
central, and setting up an
application is extremely easy.
In other cloud
providers, you have
to go through a myriad of
set up paths, between--
whether it's VPC
peering, whether it's
VPN, or going over
the public internet
to transfer or replicate the
data across those two regions.
So Google Cloud, our network,
and the global visibility
has really helped us and
made it really simple for us.
And on the frontend,
as Prajakta said,
we use layer seven
load balancer,
and we have a single global IP.
The global IP, basically,
is smart enough
to route the requests to
the closest region based
on the customer's location.
So if somebody is visiting
homedepot.com from Washington,
that request is
routed to US east,
which is in South Carolina.
Whereas if somebody was
visiting dotcom from Chicago,
the request is
routed to US central.
This also gives us the ability
to actually test DR. As in--
what happens if
US east goes away?
Or what happens if
US central goes away?
We want to make sure
that we can survive
the loss of a single zone in
a region, or a complete region
outage, and not
affect our reliability
or SLO back to our customers.
So this architecture enabled
us to easily achieve that.
In the future, if you wanted
to add another region,
whether it is US
west or the newly
announced California region,
it becomes very simple.
We don't have to do
any DNS record changes.
We don't have to make any
changes anywhere else other
than just adding the
VMs in the right region.
And the traffic
automatically gets routed,
and customers benefit from
increased performance.
As I said, we run
out of six zones.
So what does a zone look like?
Basically every zone is
its own independent copy
of the entire website.
As you can see, we
run only on VMs.
We do not do containers today.
The main reasons for using
VMs are network isolation,
segmentation, and
data persistence.
Containers, we
are looking at it.
Someday maybe we'll look at it.
Each VM runs only
one microservice,
and we have smaller VMs
that just scale out.
As you can see,
basically we have
clusters of different
services that
just scale out using
auto scaling based
on traffic demand.
Each zone also has a
service registry cluster.
So when new services
come up, they
register their services in
the service registry cluster
and are visible to the
clients in the same zone.
The load balancing from client
to services in the same zone
is through a client
side load balancing.
We don't use internal
load balancer, mostly
in part because ILB
was not available
when dotcom went to life.
Zone is our fault
isolation domain
so that the blast
radius is contained.
Any faults or any issues
that we have in one zone
don't propagate into regional
falls or global falls.
The other cool thing
that we do is actually,
basically-- as you can see,
we have databases per service.
So if a service
needs a database,
it gets its own database.
There is no database sharing
between multiple microservices.
Service A, if it
wants a database,
it has its own database cluster.
Service D, whether it's examples
of shipping or promotion,
would have its own
database cluster.
And there is network
firewall rules
that limit the access
between the right service
to the right database.
Service A here cannot
access Service D.
The other thing that
we do is our services,
when they want to
talk to the database,
the credentials are not stored
in any config files, property
files, or encrypted
file systems.
We actually have a secret
registry cluster per zone.
And whenever any VM comes up,
it talks to our secret history,
gets the DB credentials
dynamically per VM,
so every VM gets its
own DB credentials.
There is no shared DB
credentials across VMs.
That enables us to contain
any issues that we have
and be absolutely sure that
the environment is secure.
Awesome.
So we began this journey about
15 months ago, learned a lot,
partnered with Google.
They helped us learn
quite a few things,
and I'm sure they
learned a lot from us.
It's been a great partnership.
So I just want to
leave you with--
what are the key lessons
learned as part of this journey?
We are about 75%
into the migration.
So about 75% of
homedepot.com traffic
is now sorted out
of Google, and we
will finish this in the
next five to six months.
We did a pretty
good job in actually
moving into microservice
architecture,
but we dumped all
our microservices
into a single GCP Project.
So we didn't follow
the same principles
in choosing the project size.
So GCP project size matters.
We have hundreds, thousands
of VMs in one GCP project.
You run into limitations
between instance quarters,
console becoming really
slow, many people
working in the same project.
So flavors-- break
up your GCP projects
into smaller projects as well.
As you can see, one of the
biggest benefits of cloud
is autoscaling.
So we don't have
to pre-provision
the infrastructure that
we need for peak demand.
We leverage autoscaling
quite heavily,
and GCP autoscaling
works really well.
The VM instances
spin up in 14 seconds
and are ready to take traffic.
But make sure when your
VM instances spin up,
there are no external
dependencies.
Some of our applications,
like search,
they download huge
index files from storage
when a VM boots up.
The index file is somewhere
around three to five gigabytes.
That takes time, and
search engines typically
need warm up time before
they can sort traffic.
The way autoscaling is
designed, and the way
we actually route traffic, as
soon as an instance comes up,
guest register in
the service registry,
it's ready to take traffic.
So we've seen issues where
instances are set up,
but the performance
actually goes down.
Because traffic is
routed, and the VMs
are struggling to
sort the traffic.
So make sure that the external
dependencies are minimized
as part of your bootstrap.
Telemetry-- what's the
telemetry patterns?
On-prem-- we used
logs to do telemetry.
So basically logs are used for
HTTP response codes, latency,
and availability.
We ported the same
pattern into the cloud,
and it gave us similar metrics.
But in Cloud, you want
even more metrics.
You just don't want the
regular availability latency.
We want key business metrics.
You want metrics around, hey,
how much memory am I using?
How much memory am I using to
serve this particular request?
Is the CPU low or high on
one segment of requests?
Those are not
available if you just
rely on log-based telemetry.
So we are actually
moving to StatsD.
Today, the log-based
telemetry is
through the google-fluentd
and collectd plugins.
We're going to move to StatsD.
The application itself uses
the StatsD library, exposes
whatever metrics they want to
expose directly into StatsD,
and then StatsD communicates
to the Google monitoring API
for a different set of metrics.
And last but not the
least, resiliency--
when you're running on-prem,
you assume the network
is going to be stable.
You assume the file system
is going to be available.
There's not a whole lot of
cross zone interaction, cross DC
interactions.
But in public cloud,
you have-- as I said,
we run across six zones.
There's a lot of
network connections,
a lot of microservices.
We have cross
location connections.
Resiliency is key.
For example, as part
of the migration,
we had one service in
Google Cloud reaching out
to, let's say, header
service, basically
the header bar that shows up
at the top navigation bar.
That was running on-prem.
The service always assumed
that the data returned
is going to be right, or if
the data was not available,
just show the error
message back to the user.
And some instances, because
of the network connectivity
between Google and Home
Depot on-prem data center,
the data was not returned,
or it was an error.
And the user saw the page
without the top navigation bar.
So make sure you have
resiliency built in.
Don't assume network is
going to be available.
Don't just assume that, hey,
I connected to a service
instance, it returned me some
data or returned an error,
and do not retry.
Make sure you have some
retry policies built in,
so that you can show
the right messages
and have the right resiliency
for your customers.
And that's it.
So I'd like to introduce
Prajakta back for the demo.
[APPLAUSE]
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So
thank you, Ravi.
It's always great when
customers come here,
and then they talk about
they're real pain points,
their real world deployments.
Nothing can beat that.
Whatever we say before,
it doesn't matter.
So I did want to take
the opportunity to thank
Ravi and the Home Depot.
They have been
phenomenal partners.
And like he said,
they learned from us,
but we learned a whole
lot more from them,
especially on the pain
points of enterprises
and then how to make
sure that Google Cloud is
the cloud for enterprises
and cloud natives.
In the same train, we wanted to
actually end this presentation
with some action.
So we wanted to give you a sneak
preview at our IPv6 global load
balancing.
And with that I'm going to
ask our friends at the back
to play the demo for us.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hi, everyone.
This is Mike Columbus
with Google Cloud,
and I'm going to take you
through IPv6 integration
with the Google Cloud
global load balancer.
Let's now take a look
at our configuration
for our global load balancer.
The first thing you'll
notice is that we
have a single IPv4 address
that's reachable via anycast
to Google's points of presence.
Since the load balancer
is a global entity,
we can also see that we have two
backends in different regions
within Google Cloud Platform.
The first, europe-west1,
the second, us-east1.
Both instance groups
are configured
for three instances
and will auto scale
based on load balancer usage.
We now have a new requirement
to add IPv6 termination
on our global load balancer.
Let's show you how
that's configured.
First, we'll go into our
external IP addresses,
and we can see
that we've already
reserved an IPv6 address.
Let's now add this to our
load balancer frontend
by editing its configuration.
We'll select frontend
configuration
and add our reserved IPv6
address to the load balancer.
We'll select done and update.
While we're waiting
for our IPv6 address
to be attached to
our load balancer,
let's go into Cloud DNS and
look at our manage zones.
We can see we have a zone
for gcpnetworking.com.
Let's add an IPv6
record to this zone.
We'll do this by adding a record
set for www.gcpnetworking.com
of type quad A, and we'll
paste in our IPv6 address
for our load balancer.
We'll then click create.
With our records
in place, let's now
connect to
www.gcpnetworking.com.
You can see we have both
IPv4 and v6 records in place.
We'll connect to the
site using Chrome.
Our website has been configured
to provide us information
about the connection.
The first thing you see
is our client IP address,
which is an IPv6 address.
The client then connects
to our load balancer,
which is also an IPv6
address, as you can see here.
The load balancer then proxies
this connection to IPv4,
to our backend, which
lives in us-east1-d.
In this connection,
I was load balanced
to a backend in US
east, which makes sense
since I'm from Boston.
But how would this look for
a client based in Europe?
Let's remote into a machine
in Europe to find out.
Here, we'll connect again
to www.gcpnetworking.com.
When I connect to
the site, you can
see that I'm load balanced
to a Europe backend,
and you can see that this
one lives in europe-west1-b.
Thank you for your time today.
You can see on Google
Cloud Platform,
we've configured a globally
available IPv6 load balance
and solution using anycast
in about the time it
takes to make a cup of coffee.
[APPLAUSE]
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So
you're the first set
of people to actually
view this demo,
so thank you for
staying with us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]